i have been called many names  vengeance the spiky supernova but you  may call me  sorry blue  justice  here we go  hello  hedgehog  you're never going to get my power oh  contrairemover  meet knuckles  i was expecting more of a fight  so nice when diabolical evil lives up to  the height  that wasn't too bad  seriously pretending to be batman blue  justice trademark pending  and here we go  get your heart out sean white  papa's got a brand new stash  [Music]  oh boy there are two of them now  you're never going to get my power  do i look like i need your power  sonic the hedgehog 2  where  are my manners sonic meet knuckles  so nice when diabolical evil lives up to  the height  [Music]  you